comment faire fortune en juin 42 astier
d'horizon et nury donc comme son nom
l'indiqué ça se passe en juin 40
juste avant l'arrivée des allemands à
paris l'exode a déjà commencé et en
faisant un tour dans la banque de france
le responsable découvre que il a oublié
d'envoyer tout l'or au canada et qu'il
en reste 2 tonnes dans les coffres
évidemment ça tombe pas dans l'oreille
d'un sourd il ya le convoyeur le
convoyeur de fonds qui est chargé
d'amener ce butin à bordeaux va
contacter des amis à lui et va se
constituer peu à peu une équipe dont on
peut les qualifier de bras cassés qui
vont prendre cher en chasse par dont ce
fourgon on est en plein exode
évidemment la route entre paris et
bordeaux et remplis de voitures de gens
à pied de charette fin de tous ces gens
qui veulent absolument fuir avant que
l'armée allemande arrive
l'armée allemande en plus de sa survol
ces convois et irak ou à coup d'avion
donc c'est une sorte de road movie de
polar
ils sont tous dans l'ensemble pas très
doué
on a un ancien un ancien la wehrmacht
qui est le pilote du camion qui suit le
fourgon on a un corps ce fanatique qui
ne veut absolument pas être assimilé à
tous ces français qui fuit qui fuient
les allemands on a une jeune femme qui
est experte pour manipuler les explosifs
et pour ouvrir les coffres enfin voilà
toute cette petite de toute cette petite
troupe dans le camion qui suivent le
fourgon et à qui il arrive tout un tas
d'aventurés toutes plus loufoques les
unes que les autres
c'est plutôt réussi c'est l'adaptation
d'un roman de signac
voilà c'est assez drôle ça montre aussi
un petit peu comment dans l'est dans les
situations un peu extrême et d'urgence
c'est toujours des gens qui essayent de
s'en sortir et qui arrive plus ou moins
voilà c'est une bonne bd et ça a été
écrit par le scénariste de il était une
fois en france était également une série
de bandes dessinées sur la seconde
guerre mondiale donc daniel cohen ou
déclinent tout l'historique de la mise
en place de la croissance et différents
échanges commerciaux de la préhistoire
jusqu'à notre époque contemporaine
donc il vient définir tous ces échanges
qui se sont mises en place et pour lui
les deux gros points 2
d'inflexion de l'histoire c'est surtout
la la création de l'agriculture avec son
explosion démographique et ensuite ça a
été la révolution industrielle et
scientifique
l'auteur se poser la question de quelle
sera la troisième révolution
copernicienne qui viendra vraiment
réformer notre mode économique de
fonctionnement donc l'auteur se prend
pour enfin se prend prendre principe du
modèle danois finalement comme solution
à cette question et surtout comme adage
est comme comme modèle de réflexion de
puteaux la qualité que la quantité
c'est un petit album pour les enfants à
partir de 3 ans on va suivre les 3
p'tits cochons et le chaperon rouge
enfants ils ont tous un projet c'est que
quand ils seront grands
ils vont absolument martyrisé le loup en
permanence sauf que le loup il va
entendre tout ça c'est encore un petit
loup et il va prendre une grande
décision
c'est un album pour petits cartonné
c'est l'intérêt d'un tel album c'est de
faire découvrir aux enfants les
personnages des contes de fées
classiques comme le petit chaperon rouge
les trois petits cochons
c'est également l'occasion d'en
découvrir de nouveaux on peut le dire un
certain nombre de fois aux enfants
inventé ce que le petit chaperon rouge
pourrait faire au loup quand elle sera
grande
ou ce que vous pourrez faire des trois
petits cochons et donc c'est également
l'occasion évidemment de découvrir les
personnages de contes de fées dans un
autre contexte
des contes de fées traditionnel c'est
plutôt drôle et pour les plus grands on
a un autre album donc cet album qui est
plutôt pour les enfants de à partir de 5
ans donc la petite soeur du chaperon
rouge de didier l'évier de clotilde
perrin aux éditions milan donc on
connaît tous le petit chaperon rouge la
grand-mère le loup mais ce qu'on ne sait
pas c'est que le petit chaperon rouge a
une petite soeur qui s'appelle carlotta
alors carlotta la célébrité les
paillettes la jet set ça n'intéresse pas
du tout le petit chaperon rouge passe sa
vie à signer des autographes de la grand
mère
elle se fait refaire des des soins des
massages dans des spas elle ce qu'elle
aime c'est se promener dans la forêt et
découvrir tous les animaux de la forêt
et un jour elle va rencontrer le loup
qui n'est plus du tout le grand méchant
loup il a vieilli la plus haute dans ils
mangent que de la bouillie et vont
devenir très amis et se loue va lui
faire découvrir toute la population de
la forêt tous les animaux des contes de
fées et un jour carlotta surprend une
conversation entre le petit chaperon
rouge et sa grand mère elle va le faire
un immense parc d'attraction dans la
forêt ce qui va détruire le lieu
d'habitation de tous et de tous ses
nouveaux amis donc elle décide de
déménager la fois c'est un très beau
conte écologique qui permet également de
découvrir tous les personnages des
contes de fées on peut les identifier
puisque le dessin est vraiment très
clair on découvre même charles perrault
qui selon l'auteur vit là depuis
toujours et écrit quelque chose sur la
forêt d'escudé qui se passe un événement
voilà c'est assez drôle c'est assez
touchant aussi parce que carlotta là
qu'une envie c'est de se préserver son
environnement mais elle a aucune
rancoeur envers le petit chaperon rouge
et sa grand mère voilà un bel album pour
les enfants à partir de 5 ans qui vivra
kimura c'est la question centrale de cet
ouvrage de savoir qui arrivent à
survivre dans des moments soit de
pandémie de guerre de famine et la
question donc de qui sera écarté dans un
groupe où normalement tout le monde doit
survivre enfin la question centrale donc
et philosophique c'est finalement qui
écarté et qui conserve à vie alors il
est aussi question d'éthique morale et
d'éthique médicale dans ce livre
concernant par exemple les greffons a
qui ont des dix finalement certains
greffon sur des cadavres
aussi concernant tous les vaccins à qui
on dédie les vaccins alors se pose la
réflexion de la question économique ou
de la question humanitaire dont toute la
réflexion du livre va se porter sur
comment réagir vis-à-vis de ces crises
et quelles décisions doit-on prendre
vis-à-vis de tout ça ce que moi j'ai
trouvé très troublant et finalement très
intéressant et très profond dans ce
livre c'est que l'auteur met en
perspective des événements historiques
comme la shoah comme la guerre comme la
famine en afrique et à le mettre en
perspective vis-à-vis de fiction
contemporaine
donc elle met par exemple spider man qui
a le choix entre sauver une vingtaine de
gamins qui sont bloqués dans un
téléphérique ou sauver mary jane
voilà donc cette façon de convaincre que
ce soit les romans jeunesse où toutes
les fictions contemporaines d'avoir
cette ce choix de sélection entre qui
doit rester et qui doit doit mourir
l'auteur s'articule tout autour de don
de nos fictions qui sont là de tous les
jours que l'on peut voir soit dans le
roman soit dans nos films et ces
questions-là reste aussi central sur ces
fictions tout au long du livre l'auteur
nous montre le lien qui peuvent donc
exister entre les fictions
contemporaines et tous les événements
tragiques qui ont pu avoir lieu durant
toute l'histoire et que finalement ce
n'est pas forcément le tragique qui
prend le dessus et on peut avoir une
vraie réflexion concernant ces décisions